Rachel's in Phoenix as well hey Rachel
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi mr. Ramsey thank you so much for
taking my call it's a real pleasure
honor to talk to you how can I help so
we have started the baby steps this year
you spent a lot of time at our dinner
table I don't know if you know that in
front of the guest plate right so I'm
staying there at the table yeah
so we bought a car late last year we had
two older cars and we were trying to
downsize to one vehicle in a smaller
payment and we thought we made the right
decision and it turns out we didn't okay
so we are so I did my research after I
started reading your book trying to
figure out how to get out from under
this car it's about $18,000 underwater
and I can't find a credit union or
anybody who's willing to refinance that
amount with us that's not a shock so you
must say you rolled a ton of underwater
from the other two cars into this deal
yes it must have been a ridiculous
interest rate that's what the whole
thing was we had one of my husband's car
was of a thirteen percent interest rate
and mine was at a 6% interest rate so
when we went to the dealership you said
what these cars are old they're their
bottom-of-the-barrel value we can get
you into a new car we can roll in the
negative equity at 2.75 percent with a
cosigner which is what we did okay so
you're at 2.7 there's only good news in
the story so far what's your household
income so Caicos we bring home about
five thousand dollars a month okay and
you owe total how much on this car
forty-one thousand twenty-five dollars
and seventy six cents as of this month
good lord and it's really honestly mr.
Ramsey I called cause it's real
discouraging we're trying to get going
and it feels like we're almost done
before we before we before even get go
so how much was your tax refund well
that's all gone we put that into other
things but it was about forty five
hundred okay change your double we've
fuller so that you take home forty five
hundred divided by 12 or about another
four hundred dollars a month because you
got too much coming out of your check
and how much are you putting into your
401 K s so as of this month we stopped
our 401 K and have you stopped all
gimmick insurance everything but health
insurance we have so all of our
insurances are through our employer so
we have like our health insurance our
life insurance and our kids life
insurance your kid's life insurance yes
we we had a friend lose a baby this year
a small baby and we decided that we
would take out to ten thousand dollar
policies they're like three bucks a
month for our children just in case okay
all right okay you guys need to tighten
your budget down now change your W fours
make sure you've stopped all your 401 KS
which is what you're talking about get
home with as much money as you can
increase your income as much as you can
sell everything in sight put so much
stuff on Craigslist the kids are hiding
sell every thing in sight and start
paying this car down there's no way out
of this except to pay it down if it's a
big eighteen thousand dollar loan or if
it's a forty thousand dollar loan right
now it doesn't matter it's a two point
seven pay it down hard and fast hard and
fast you can do it